une cérémonie d'investiture forcément
particulière cette année covin 19 oblige
la liste des invités était réduite au
minimum seules quelques personnes ont pu
assister de près à cet événement parmi
eux il y avait d'anciens présidents tels
que george w.bush barack obama ou encore
bill clinton
pas de supporters qui ont pu accéder au
capitole sur la pelouse devant le
bâtiment il y avait quelques 190 milles
drapeau kamala harris puis joe biden ont
donc prêté serment à la mi-journée et
puis joe biden a prononcé ses premiers
mots en tant que 46e président des états
unis
un discours visant à l'unité nationale
en et course 1 le véhicule il faudra
être élue miss cours se battre contre la
haine contre nice maladie le chômage
j'aime le désespoir week-end de grâce à
l'unité nous pouvons de faire de grandes
choses des choses importantes mais font
corriger des erreurs ont donné des
choses correctes aux gens qu enseigner à
nos enfants sauvés des écoles nous
pouvons vaincre ce virus mortel souffert
de compenser le travail reconstruire à
la classe moyenne
créer un système de santé pour tous nous
pouvons faire des etats unis une fois de
plus un pionnier pour les biens dans le
monde entier à défaut de pouvoir suivre
la cérémonie d'investiture de près
quelques supporters de joe biden se sont
rassemblés à proximité du capitole pour
s'imprégner de l'ambiance ils ont suivi
sur leur téléphone portable le déroulé
de cette cérémonie avec quelques
applaudissements quelques effusions de
joie également lorsque kamala harris et
joe biden ont prêté serment
pas de débordements il faut dire que le
dispositif de sécurité ici à washington
est très imposant plus de 25 mille
membres de la garde nationale ont été
déployés pour l'occasion
cela n'a pas empêché certains donc
venir à washington parfois depuis
d'autres villes des états unis c'est le
cas de ces deux hommes qui sont venus
spécialement de new york pour venir ici
à washington et suivre cette cérémonie
d'investiture c'est au micro de lucas tu
vois c'est un jour très important pour
la démocratie le processus de transition
du pouvoir est en jeu ici nous sommes
donc ici pour défendre la démocratie
en fin de compte nous voulons nous
assurer que ce processus soit disponible
pour tous ceux qui viendront après nous
c'est la chose la plus importante qui
est en jeu ici nous devions être ici
pour soutenir quelqu'un qui je pense va
vous savez nous emmener là où nous
voulons aller
je pense que biden va rendre l'amérique
à nouveau entière j'espère vraiment que
nous réunirons le pays
nous voyons beaucoup de divisions ici et
même à washington ces derniers jours
donc j'espère qu'il réunira le pays et
nous donnera quelques points communs et
nous aidera à réaliser que nous ne
sommes pas si éloignés les uns des
autres
joe biden qui pour son premier tweet en
tant que président des états unis a
expliqué qu'il ne voulait pas perdre de
temps et se mettre rapidement au travail
dans sa ligne de mire 17 décret
présidentiel qui vise notamment à
détricoter une partie des mesures qui
ont été prises par donald trump pendant
son mandat on pense par exemple à la
réintégration des états unis dans la
corde paris sur le climat la fin du
muslim ban ou encore l'arrêt de la
construction du chantier sur la
frontière entre les etats-unis et le
mexique
donald trump pour sa part n'était donc
pas présent à cette cérémonie
d'investiture c'est la première fois
qu'un président des états unis boycott
volontairement une passation de pouvoir
depuis 1869 donald trump qui a quitté
washington tôt le matin pour la floride
les avant de partir il a délivré un
discours dans lequel il a souhaité bonne
chance à son successeur dans lequel il a
également vanté son bilan à la tête des
états unis et puis il a dit qu'il
reviendrait sous une forme ou une autre
on écoute donald trump
je me battrai toujours pour vous je
regarderai j'écouterai et je vous dirais
que le futur de ce pays
n'a jamais été aussi bon je souhaite à
la nouvelle administration beaucoup de
chance
beaucoup de succès je pense qu'elle aura
beaucoup de succès elle a de bonnes
fondations pour faire des choses
vraiment spectaculaire et je le redis
nous l'avons mise dans des conditions
telles que ça n'a jamais été fait
auparavant et ce malgré la pire pandémie
qui nous est frappé depuis je suppose
1917 en dépit de cela ce que nous avons
fait a été incroyable et nous n'aurions
pas pu le faire sans lui donc c'est
juste un au revoir je vous aime je
reviendrai d'une manière ou d'une hausse
selon les médias américains il n'y a pas
eu de contacts directs entre donald
trump et joe biden pas de coup de fil
entre les deux hommes seulement une
lettre laissée par donald trump a
l'intention de joe biden mais le contenu
de cette lettre est pour le moment
inconnue